- And we need to mention everybody
that Troy is the first deaf male actor
to earn an Oscar nomination
(audience cheering) and to win
an individual SAG Award.
I mean it's exciting.
So how does that feel?
- Of course I'm extremely excited
and it's great to finally be recognized.
It means that our peers are
accepting our work as artists,
not because we're deaf,
we're just actors who happen to be deaf.
And we're being recognized for our talent.
And so I'm so glad.
It's been a long and tough journey for me,
and I feel like I've received
an honorary PhD when
getting these nominations
(audience clapping)
and it's like I'm finally
arrived at their level
and I feel so blessed.
You know the decisions
that I made in my life brought me here
but Marlee was such an
important role model
and she kept me alive.
She gave Daniel and I hope.
- Yeah definitely.
- And so Marley
was a great representative
for the deaf community
for so many years, and
now we're able to come up.
And so I'm so grateful to Marlee
(audience claps) for that.
- I agree.
- And it's so interesting
'cause Marlee we've seen in movies,
I've seen movies, TV, I've
seen Marlee in so many things.
And it's like it's one of those things
where it's like why are we just seeing one
like one person?
Like she is amazing
but like there has to
be a whole community.
And I feel like Marlee
was it very important
for you to be a part of
this movie in particular?
Because it not only showcases
like your gifts, your talent as an actor,
but also to get help
highlight other actors
that just happen to be deaf
that love what they do
and excel at what they do.
Is this just such an
important project for you?
- Absolutely I mean it's been
35 years being in the industry
that I've tried to spread
the message to people
that yes I'm here but
I'm not the only one.
There are so many other
deaf actors out there,
deaf directors, deaf writers,
and Coda's, people who
can sign and who can act.
And it's sometimes you know
it would fall on deaf ears,
that sounds ironic,
but it takes collaboration,
it takes one to listen,
to spread the message, it
takes work, it takes homework.
But at the end of the day we are here,
we're focused on doing
whatever it is we can do,
we can continue to make noise.
But the key is collaboration,
it's collaboration,
(audience claps) in all ways.